alright a you're just up at bungie
checking out house of wolves
specifically what we can talk about
today PvP and trials of Osiris so much
go ahead and tell me what that is all
about sure so you know it's funny we had
this conversation last week almost but
this time i actually have details to
flesh out for you Charles of Osiris it
is a new endgame PvP activity that's
three on three elimination mode is a new
game tight it's like a death match game
type but it has revivals this is
Bungie's new kind of like if you're
really into pvp here's your kind of like
almost like a raid but obviously not a
raid but it does have almost like red
like rewards the raider like rewards are
based off of wins so if you win two wins
you get a blue package three wins you
get another kind of blue package at five
wins you get the armor the weekly armor
that the vendor has at six wins there's
a legendary package at seven wins
there's a weapon that rotates weekly as
well and then at eight wins there is a
another legendary package in order to
get into the trials of Osiris you need a
trials passage a trials passage is
basically like a ticket but it's kind of
like your scorecard your visual aid so
to speak and you can have three losses
per charles passage but you want to try
to accumulate as many wins as you can
depend on how many wins you get you can
buy whatever the vendor has and
everything before it so like if you win
five times you can buy the armor and the
two blue package or if you have seven
wins you can buy the weapon and the
legendary package and everything before
that this is a endgame activity for PvP
it's going to be really intense there is
no matchmaking so you're going to need
to have you know two friends or two
people we find from destiny lfg to party
up with and it's actually really fun but
it's also really stressful because
there's a lot of teamwork going on and
so you know you're trying to figure out
the map for the week which there's only
one map per week there's no actual
rotation and the reason Bungie decided
to do that is because they want the
players to be able to really hone in on
the strategies and
in the map so that they can go okay
let's all go this way or let's make a
play over here and also that will change
the armors that you wear right like you
want to try to build up super more so
maybe you're wearing a helmet gives more
orbs or something like that so there's
really a kind of like a deep meta with
this and it would be interesting to see
how it works because the way they look
at it is that the best teams are gonna
win there is no like balance of like
you're you have a twins I have seven
wins that sounds like a fair fight it
could just be like you're on your
seventh win I just started and you might
roll me because your team's far really
good if it's got seven wins so that's
kind of my one slight concern is that
there is no balance so to speak I gotta
ask though like is that do you think
that's like smart game designer do you
think that's just kind of like a cop-out
because this game is typically had a lot
of barriers to entry and like over time
those barriers have been too much for a
lot of players for example like an array
getting five people together every
single week is kind of a big deal for a
lot of people and a lot of people can't
do that like what is this bringing to
the table that wasn't in destiny
previously there's always going to be
small barriers of entry to these kind of
things but bungee is trying to open
those up right like you said a raid
requires five other people at least in
this case this only requires two more
people and that like I said even in the
office we can always easily get kind of
one or two people to play with us if
they're free right but getting five
people is hard so I think that's already
good that's like a plus right you're
getting a smaller group so it's not as
hard to play but in terms of just the
balance part I mean yeah you might get
rolled a couple times but I mean you
have five days it's a weekend event it's
Friday to reset which is like tuesday
morning so you have plenty of times to
try and also there's actually two sets
of trials of osiris armor so one is
gated through wins which is like the
gold colored one that everyone's going
to want to try to get but there's also
like a lower tiered one that they didn't
specify like what it looks like but you
can just win randomly from plane to
plane the trials of Osiris so you still
like people will still have avenues to
get like
and gear from the trials it's just how
prestigious you are but I think this is
going to be fun because it's kind of
like wow arena where you did that weekly
and it was you know either you do two on
two three on three or five on five in
this case it's a three on three and it's
something for the PDP players to look
forward to and also the wider community
if they want to get into it right and
that there was one thing I didn't even
talk about that kind of helps you
through the trials of Osiris which are
consumables that you can buy from
brother bands who's the npc one of them
gives you a mercy mercy of Osiris where
you know it forgives you for your first
loss or there's like the boon of Osiris
we win your first match it counts as two
wins so there they did add these little
touches to help you get through the
trials of Osiris even if you're not like
an intense hardcore PvP player and those
are purchased through passage coins
which is like a new currency but it's
something you get from the crucifix so
when you play the crucible you can earn
passage and then something that's really
cool this time is bungee has realized
that like the crucible itself wasn't as
rewarding as maybe some people wanted it
to be or maybe it just wasn't enticing
enough to make people that like PvE
content a lot to play it they're really
making it rewarding this time because
the daily mission now for the crucible
will give you a reward pack and in that
reward pack there's Engram most of light
and passage coins and like maybe some
other things too and then on top of that
every piece will match now you'll get
double the reputation double the marks
there's going to be more in grams that
drop so they're really trying to like
push you to be like hey this is actually
worth playing today being more of a PVE
guy is this stuff enough to get you into
crucible again I mean for me I oh I I
generally focused on PVE because that's
mainly where the where the good loot was
but now that you know trials of Osiris
does have its own specific set and it
has its own weapons and the crucible is
going to you know drop more Ingram's
potentially totally back into it you
know there's four new crucible maps one
is the thieves den which is on Venus
it's really cool it's like a fallen
hideout timekeeper which is the
PlayStation 4 exclusive map which is
actually interestingly enough the only
PlayStation 4 exclusive this time
so there's no strike or weapon that the
Xbox players you know will miss out on
this time but the timekeeper maps really
cool too it's kind of like this
clockwork structure that the vex made
authors these like forcefield walls
almost that like you look like you could
kind of jump through and face through it
but you actually can actually kill
someone trying to jump through is pretty
funny and then there's a another map
called widows court which actually was
probably the funnest one for me because
it kind of reminded me of like a cod
kind of like map and cod multiplayer
obviously as fun and addicting it's got
really long narrow streets where you can
snipe for once even like one of the
control points is in a church so kind of
fight in the Church of like a
broken-down one and I think you would
like it because visually it looks really
cool I'm gonna ask vehicle maps yeah so
unfortunately there aren't any vehicle
maps this time I did ask bungie know
like so what was the thought process
behind you know not adding a vehicle map
this time if they've had some before
right and they added one in the dark
glow but basically they said they were
focused on these maps and it kind of
makes sense because they're smaller to
medium sized maps which kind of fits the
mold of what trials of Osiris is about
right like it's a three-on-three
deathmatch type gameplay so you want to
not have to find each other and vehicles
obviously affect that and because the
trials of Osiris is a power base so you
know it's going to matter what gear
you're weighing what level you are you
can start the trials of Osiris at level
Tony I'm not really sure why you would
want to go in at 20 because you'll get
murdered by any 30 plus of course stay
tuned you know may six I'll have more
information we'll have another
discussion this time around PvE the
prison of elders the new strike and also
just like upgrading ascending your
weapons and gear that's very interesting
is very fun I can't talk about it
unfortunately I had a lot of fun a lot
of strategies that you're gonna have to
think about so awesome thanks day yeah